madame monsieur bonsoir voici les petits
trucs et nous allons développer dans ce
journal catastrophe mais revenir en
allemagne la vitesse excessive pourrait
être à l'origine du déraillement de
l'express venant d'amsterdam avec 300
passagers à bord bilan provisoire neuf
morts et 20 blessés graves
c'est demain que le plan anti violence
de claude allègre commencera et mis en
place le témoignage dans ce journal de
david 13 ans il a eu le courage de
briser la loi du silence il n'a pas été
entendu
la parole des enfants ni sans doute dans
quelques heures hillary clinton se
lancera officiellement dans la campagne
des sénatoriales portrait d'une battante
qui compte bien arracher le poste de
sénateur de l'état de new york
cinéma avec cette légende du chevalier
sans tête un conte merveilleux et
cauchemardesque que mise en scène par
tim burton avec pour héros johnny depp
dans l'actualité de ce dimanche cette
catastrophe ferroviaire près de cologne
en allemagne le train de nuit qui
assurait la liaison amsterdam bâle a
déraillé percutant au passage une maison
d'habitation à proximité de la petite
garde brûle la vitesse très excessive
semblera l'origine du drame
pour l'instant le bilan fait état de
neuf morts et d'une vingtaine de blessés
graves
d'autres passagers pourraient être
encore prisonnier de l'amas de tôles et
les vernis
le pavillon est réduit un véritable tas
de gravats les habitants eux sont
indemnes
une chance inouïe que n'ont pas eu les
300 passagers du train de nuit amsterdam
balles hier soir leur convoi a déraillé
et percuté une maison de plein fouet
neuf morts une centaine de blessés est
toujours une vingtaine de passagers
porté disparu
on a fait deux ou trois tonneaux des
arbres sont passés par la fenêtre
mes amis est blessé au thorax mais à
part ça dieu merci tout va bien selon
les premiers éléments de l'enquète le
compoix aurait-on fait dérailler alors
qu'il empruntait une déviation un excès
de vitesse est à l'origine de l'accident
on peut constater qu'à minuit une minute
et 10 secondes
le train a passé le chantier de travaux
avant la garde brûle sur le chantier la
vitesse était limitée à 40 kilomètres à
l'heure c'est alors que le conducteur a
ralenti et respecter la limitation de
vitesse
quelques minutes plus tard pour une
raison encore inexpliquée le conducteur
aurait accéléré jusqu'à atteindre la
vitesse
122 kilomètres à l'heure c'est ce qu'a
révélé l'analyse de la boîte noire
c'est le deuxième accident ferroviaire
survenu en allemagne en l'espace de deux
ans en juin 98
la catastrophe ferroviaire déchets d
avec les sens une victime mais en direct
de brune nous rejoignant bertrand cocq
nous l'avons vu un important dispositif
de secours est sur place quel est le
point de la situation est tombée de la
nuit et bienvenue à trice 20 heures
après l'accident les sauveteurs sont
toujours au travail ici dans la petite
gare de brühl près de cologne et toute
la journée ils ont peiné à démêler à
dégager les amoncellements de tôle que
sont les wagons du train couchette avec
toujours bien sûr la crainte d'y
retrouver de nouveaux corps
vous savez béatrice que le bilan
s'établit ce soir à neuf morts et
quelques 80 blessés dont dix graves
la plupart de ses victimes étaient des
vacanciers qui se rendaient en suisse à
bâle pour faire du ski
et puis on sait aussi depuis cet
après-midi hélène verne nous l'a dit
avec l'analyse de la boîte noire que la
cause de la suite de l'accident était la
vitesse ce train allait beaucoup trop
vite plus de 120 km heure sur une
portion de voie où la vitesse était
limitée à 40 pour cause de travaux alors
ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est pourquoi ce
train allait si vite
celui qui pourrait nous le dire c'est le
chauffeur de la motrice c'est un
allemand de 28 ans il a été légèrement
blessé mais il est surtout très choqué
il aurait même été admis dans une unité
de soins psychiatriques et les médecins
ont demandé aux enquêteurs d'attendre
quelques jours avant de l'interroger
merci et bertrand cocq et de ces
précisions en autriche york haider
multiplient ces derniers jours les
déclarations maniant aussi bien les
excuses que les phrases pensive
c'est demain qu'il devrait tenir une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui à la
télévision le chef de l'extrême droite
envisageait une enquête parlementaire
pour août trahison politique contre ce
qui aurait mobilisé l'étranger pour
faire obstacle à son arrivée au pouvoir
le numéro deux de son parti occupe
désormais vous savez l'une des plus
hautes fonctions de l'état puisque susan
rice passeur et le nouveau vice
chancelier d'autriche la première femme
à occuper ce poste
elle porte le difficile sur nom de cobra
royal
voici pourquoi nos envoyés spéciaux à
nous fasciner patrick dissimuler le
rencontrer une femme radieuse danse la
valse bras de son mari
c'est la nouvelle vice chancelière la
première de l'histoire autrichienne
et si susan rice passeur ancien juriste
de 39 ans dans cette hier soir à
klagenfurt
c'est bien grâce à jorg haider pas
seulement parce qu'il était
l'organisateur du bal mais aussi parce
que c'est lui qui l'a invitée en
politique elle fut son attaché de presse
pendant huit ans c'est une fidèle parmi
les fidèles ce qu'un bateau jour d'hui
en autriche
c'est une sorte de normalisation de la
démocratie et je suis très mécontent les
réactions européennes
j'espère qu'ils seront suffisamment fair
play pour nous juger selon ce que nous
ferons et passeront leurs préjugés
hier soir au bal de klagenfurt c'est
elle qui a descendu l'escalier la
première mais ces riders qui tenait la
vedette
juste après sa nomination la télévision
autrichienne demandait d'ailleurs à
susan rice passeur si elle n'était pas
une marionnette de rider c'est lui le
leader de notre parti c'est lui qui a
rendu possible ce succès grâce à tout le
travail de ces dernières années susan
rice passeur est né à brandão là où est
né plaisent c'est apparemment le seul
lien qu'on puisse faire entre les deux
selon les observateurs de la vie
politique autrichienne contrairement à
rider elle n'a jamais dérapé sur ce
registre il y a des gens qui sont
vraiment à l'extrême droite au sp eux
deviennent et qui ont dit des choses
inacceptables sur le passé mais elle
s'est toujours tenue au second plan sur
ce terrain c'est la femme élégante du
parti la représentante de chagrin
sur son action politique peu de choses
on sait que député européen elle milita
contre l'euro la voilà cinq ans plus
tard chargé de charme et une europe plus
que réticente au nom de jorg haider et
puis cette autre déclaration de jorg
haider qui a demandé au gouvernement
autrichien de prendre une initiative
pour compenser les allemands chasser des
sudètes à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale comme pour dédommager les
huiles les juifs autrichiens victimes
des nazis ou chapitre judiciaire le
procureur général de la cour de
cassation en annonçant sa volonté de
faire casser le procès du drac drame
dans lequel une classe près de grenoble
avait été emporté par un lâcher d'eau
cette proposition juridique pourrait à
terme avoir de nombreuses répercussions
en effet le risque de remettre en cause
l'ensemble de ces affaires où il ya d'un
côté des victimes et de l'autre sans
intention de nuire des personnes qui
sont à l'origine de faute involontaire
les explications de dominique werber un
simple lâchers d'eau à un barrage edf
près de grenoble
plus bas une classe venues observer des
castors au bord de la rivière bilan de
la catastrophe du drac en décembre 95
sept morts six écoliers et une
accompagnatrice enjoint 81,18 la justice
condamne trois fonctionnaires edf
la directrice d'école l'institutrice et
la ville de grenoble à des peines de
prison avec sursis et à des amendes
aujourd'hui le procureur général près la
cour de cassation jean françois bourgeot
l'un veut faire annuler ce jugement pour
le haut magistrat la faute commise par
les prévenus n'est pas suffisamment
grave pour justifier une condamnation
donc un procès une annonce faite hier
lors d'un colloque intitulé fossiles
toujours un coupable
plusieurs magistrats avocats et lui se
sont montrés favorables à cette
proposition qui tend à limiter une
pénalisation de la vie publique
la solution c'est de resserrer le champ
de la justice pénale de ceux ci pour
tout le monde pas seulement pour les
élus bien sûr de prévoir par exemple que
on abandonnera les condamnations pénales
pour une simple imprudence ou une simple
négligence
l'absence de procès l'absence de
condamnation pénale comme ici après
l'avalanche
or c'est l' angoisse la crainte des
victimes où il y aura pas de procès où
il y aura un procès tronqué et spa avec
une seule personne le 4 ou 5
on n'arrivera pas à déterminer
l'enchaînement des causes qui ont
entraîné la catastrophe
et donc ça n'aura aucune valeur
pédagogique en octobre dernier
jacques chirac s'était lui aussi
inquiété de cette judiciarisation
excessive autrement dit le procès à tout
prix au parlement au ministère de la
justice ont réfléchi sur la
responsabilité pénale des élus des
décideurs
hier les magistrats sont entrés dans la
course laissant derrière eux les
victimes
c'est demain que le dispositif anti
violence de claude allègre devrait se
mettre progressivement en place la tâche
ne sera pas facile face aux agressions
on demande aux enfants d'avoir du
courage celui de dire et de porter
plainte faut-il encore que la parole des
enfants soit entendue et qu'ensuite
justice soit faite
voici l'histoire de david 13 ans qui a
osé briser la loi du silence en dehors
de sa famille personne ne l'a cru
la justice a classé la faire sans suite
et la nuque eric de l'agneau t3 sont pas
reliés par derrière et monté par les fai
seront soulevées au jeu et jeter un
espalier qu'elle jette en l'air du port
c'était très long et je fermais les yeux
j'avais pas su le morbihan cette chute
qui lui a valu une entorse à la cheville
et un mois de plâtre
david ne pouvait pas la cacher à ses
parents alors il a commencé à parler et
puis il a tout raconté raconter les
sévices que ses agresseurs trois élèves
de sa classe lui faisait subir depuis
sept mois
mais tant pis mais des dix juifs dans la
nuit que les coups d'épée dans l'eau
dans le ventre et je disais rien puis
c'était par période et un jour ils m'ont
jeté aux toilettes sans révision vers la
porte
comment ce coup et ils vont obliger un
mur inné dessus et avait dit que si on
si je disais quelque choisirait taper
minceur s'ils reconnaissent c'est à
l'école qu'on est ensemble et il avait
dit qu'il tape aurait - soeur qui menait
après mois séparant des causes à leur
plainte pour violence au commissariat de
police
la direction du collège entend d'avis
depuis ses trois agresseurs séparément
leur seule punition restera une
rédaction sur le respect d'autrui pour
avoir poussé leurs camarades comme le on
n'a jamais vous pouvez exactement ce qui
s'était passé
et vu la qualité de la blessure j'allais
dire qu'il n'est pas une blessure
extraordinaire quand même donc les
lèvres dû être repoussée 1
les élèves ont reconnu avoir poussé
l'élève et sont punis ce serait ça quant
aux brimades subies par david pendant
sept mois 1 sera pas davantage évoqué le
témoignage de son meilleur ami ne sera
pas prise en compte
pas plus que le rapport établi par la
psychologue qui a écouté david pendant
plusieurs semaines faute de preuves
l'éducation nationale classe l'enquète
en dépit de ces appels officiels à
rompre la loi du silence
la parole d'un enfant ne semble pas lui
suffire source proche raconte une
histoire
enfin moi je n'en tiens pas compte en
tout cas la fabulation ça existe
l'affabulation ça existe le professeur
principal où un professeur se serait
rendu compte de quelque chose une
manière comme une autre
si personne ne s'est rendu compte de
quelque chose ce qui s'est rien passé
rien non plus aux yeux de la justice qui
n'a jamais convoqué david mais a classé
la faire sans suite
dernier recours d'un air espoir
d'obtenir un soutien
sos violences le numéro vert mis en
place par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
là encore l'écoutait approximative tu
peux ce clown et et non vraiment
et le sentiment d'injustice est totale
il ya rien de plus qu'une chose qui ait
fait qui n'est pas puni qu'on ne cherche
pas à savoir
on dit partout il faut que les entends
par là c'est très bien ici qui parle
mais s'il parlait capot ne le crois pas
je vois pas lui dire et qui parle la
sphère remonte à mai dernier à la
rentrée de septembre
javid est entré dans un collège privé et
il a souhaité apprendre le karaté c'est
une des femmes j'ai plus peur
autrefois je me conviennent à la rue
misano soeur et moi regarde et me fixer
j'ai fait baisser les yeux j'étais
content il arrive parfois qu'un gosse de
13 ans inverse les rôles et donne aux
adultes une bonne leçon près du croisic
hors bretagne
l'expérience parfaitement réussie de la
mobilisation de plusieurs dizaines de
jeunes de banlieues qui sont venus
donner un sérieux coup de main depuis
plus d'un mois pour nettoyer les plages
souillées par la marée noire
ils ont su faire leurs preuves au point
d'être les seuls civils responsable de
chantier louis carzou mahdi diawara le
temps d'une marée pour la photo
certaines âmes charitables payet haut et
fort qu'il ne resterait pas plus
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés sur les rivages
atlantiques mais elles se sont trompés
car ces jeunes bénévoles venus pour la
plupart de quartiers difficiles entament
leur cinquième semaine de lutte contre
la marée noire avec une motivation
intacte grosses nappes de 15 mètres de
long et tout ça est motivée quand envie
de l'enlever parce que franchement c'est
loctite on est responsable de soucis
donc
cet enthousiasme cette persévérance ont
fini par faire la différence alors après
un bref galop d'essai en vendée le
capitaine langlois responsable du
secteur nord de la loire atlantique les
a accueilli parmi les centaines de
militaires et de pompiers qu'il dirige
avec les mêmes matériels et surtout la
même et ses travaux de taille
j'ai rien choisi j'ai vu un gars sont
arrivés avec une équipe de jeunes de la
région parisienne pour se met à la
disposition de notre organisation
après quelques heures de briefing et de
formation 1 s'est rendu compte de la
compétence et du dévouement sur vos
plats et il est tout à fait normal
qu'ils en un dispositif au même titre
que la porte et les autres unités
constituées point est loin du cliché
banlieusards fouteur de merde
et c'était aussi quelque chose qui nous
apportait au delà de dépolluer la zone
c'était aussi d'appuyer sur cela qu'il y
avait des jeunes en banlieue en
l'occurrence en ile-de-france qu'ils
étaient prêts à se mobiliser sur les
actions citoyennes comme celles là et on
vient faire la différence
après la plage de la grande jambes et
sur la côte sauvage jeunes encadrés par
l'association les lascars sont attendus
sur les chantiers de dépollution du
croisic
reste à espérer qu'un jour il se
trouvera aussi des bénévoles pour les
aider à restaurer leur environnement
loin très loin de la mer cérémonie à la
mémoire du préfet erignac deux ans jour
pour jour après l'assassinât du préfet
de corse le rassemblement dans le
recueillement des anonymes et des élus
locaux à ajaccio arnaud goûter îles
tonga rue du colonel d'ornano il y a
deux ans claude erignac tombe est ici
abattu de trois balles
l'actuel préfet voulait cette année un
recueillement sur les lieux de
l'assassinât
pour ne pas oublier et associés la
tristesse du corps préfectoral à celle
des habitants d'ajaccio
mais derrière la rangée d'uniformes les
anonymes ne sont pas nombreux
une centaine de personnes tout au plus
sait pas qu'il s'en fout c'est la nette
impression que c'est la même chose
même constat chez les politiques peu
d'élus ont fait le déplacement
tous nos politiques sur qui nous j'ai
voté eh bien je crois qu'ils le laissent
les brosses
moi je suis une simple citoyenne mais je
les baisses que jamais après l'hommage
dans le silence quelques mots tout
simples pour afficher la détermination
de l'état
je ne peux dire qu'une chose c'est que
toutes les mises au vert
tout sera mis en oeuvre yvon collin sera
interpellé et présenté devant changer la
fuite du principal suspect alimente les
rumeurs les plus folles mais à cargèse
dans la commune divan colonna on se tait
pour cacher sa douleur où ça compte
ici encore cantonnée dans la douleur on
est dans le silence
mais ce silence et parlant pas lui-même
parce que est porteur d'une souffrance
cet anniversaire avait donc un
traumatisme que les corses ne pourront
espérer guérir tant que quelque part
l'assassin présumé du préfet erignac
court toujours politique avec ses
déclarations de françois hollande dans
l'émission d'emad de paul amar le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
est revenu sur la fameuse cagnotte de
recettes fiscales supplémentaires dont
disposerait bercy et dans le montant
officiel devrait être connu en milieu de
semaine prochaine
françois hollande appelle le
gouvernement a joué la transparence je
me propose de l'écouter vous avez dansé
20 milliards c'était les chiffres du
mois de décembre
mission que je sois davantage mais on ne
sera marqué puisque le mini doit faire
cette annonce davantage plutôt pris le
temps de trente 30 35 peut-être pas une
carotte pour le coup on aurait pu avoir
ces chiffres peut-être plus tôt c'est
peut-être des résistances
d'administrative mais en même temps ce
qui compte c'est de n'avoir maintenant
l'évaluation et avoir un débat
démocratique compris entre la gauche et
la droite au parlement
vous savez ce qu'est ce qu'on fait ces
recettes supplémentaires de la
croissance généralement quand la droite
est au pouvoir ne cachait ses déficits
moi je pense qu'il faut donner toute la
lumière sur nos propres excès d'un coup
le retour d'henri emmanuelli sur la
scène politique aujourd'hui le deuxième
tour des législatives partielles laurent
à qui vous êtes en direct de migrants il
n'y a pas de gros suspense henri
emmanuelli t est donné largement favori
effectivement élu ce soir député des
landes avec un peu plus de 65 % des
suffrages
il lui avait manqué la semaine dernière
dimanche dernier au premier tour 118
voix pour être élu au premier tour
participation voisine ce dimanche de
celle de dimanche dernier peut élever un
peu moins de la moitié de la population
de la circonscription s'est déplacé
rappelons que henri emmanuelli avait été
réélue dimanche dernier à son siège de
conseiller général du canton de mugron
le voit ici voté aujourd'hui dans son
village de laurède son adversaire robert
lucas de démocratie libérale a lui voté
en milieu de matinée dans le village
d'arte à 5 dont il est maire robert
lucas qui envisage de déposer un recours
en annulation de cette législative
partielle
ils remettent en cause l'éligibilité
d'henri emmanuelli mais pour l'heure
henri emmanuelli compte retrouver le
bureau national du parti socialiste
d'ici une semaine
il a l'intention de retrouver
l'assemblée nationale d'ici une dizaine
de jours y compris la présidence de la
commission des finances
il aura ainsi retrouvé tous ses mandats
d'avant sa condamnation dans l'affairé
urba il ya deux ans la ferrure balde
affaire de financement occulte du parti
socialiste voilà béatrice merci laurent
hakim l'actualité internationale avec en
tchétchénie l'annoncé par moscou de la
libération de grosses nîmes mettant à
terme victorieux selon vladimir poutine
à l'opération militaire dans la capitale
reste maintenant à savoir si telle est
bien la réalité est ensuite quelle sera
la tournure du conflit le retrait des
troupes russes ou bien plutôt le début
d'une guerre de maquis contre une les
indépendantistes gilles rabin france
brille c'est à ceux qui voudraient
croire qu'avec la chute de grozny la
guerre est presque fini ces images de
combattants tchétchènes gagnant
tranquillement la montagne apporte un
démenti
ils ont réussi à quitter la capitale a
siégé comme il l'avait annoncé après une
résistance remarquable que beaucoup
d'officiers russes n'ont pas eu peur de
salir
il se prépare à une autre guerre une
guérilla de montagnat
guérilla qui leur avait déjà donné la
victoire en 87 d'assises spécialement
pour continuer
je voulais acheter 500
dans grozny n'y a plus aucune résistance
l'ambiance est à la fête et au
soulagement parmi les soldats russes qui
pour la première fois peuvent se tenir à
découverts dans les ruines de la ville
sans crainte d'être frappé par une balle
peut dire que l'opération libération de
grozny est maintenant terminée dans leur
retraite de grozny les deux chaînes ont
essuyé de lourdes pertes après avoir
sauté sur une mine le chef de guerre
chamil bassaïev le pire ennemi de la
russie a été amputé du pied droit et il
a perdu beaucoup de sang bassaïev ne
pourra plus combattre en première ligne
à la tête de ces zones et c'est
peut-être la seule vraie bonne nouvelle
pour les russes la dîmière poutine doit
entretenir cette illusion de victoire
jusqu'au prochaine présidentielle du 26
mars malgré les bilans qui
s'alourdissent 13 cents soldats et
plusieurs centaines de civils tués selon
l'état major
plus de 3000 soldats tués selon les
mères de soldats et plus de quatorze
villes civ
selon les deux chaînes contre le pouvoir
iranien cet attentat hier à téhéran à
deux semaines des élections légistatives
des explosions revendiquée par
l'opposition régime islamique
ces explosions ont fait un mort et cinq
blessés dans un quartier où se situent
les bureaux des hauts responsables
politiques le détournement d'abris 727
afghan parti de kaboul qui dans un
premier temps s'est posé à tachkent la
capitale de l'ouzbékistan à cette escale
une dizaine de passages a été libérée
puis autre atterrissage au kazakhstan là
les pirates de l'air ont relâché trois
passagers enfin selon les informations
qui nous parvenaient en fin de journée
l'avion aurait décollé en direction de
moscou
avec 160 personnes à bord dont une
dizaine de pirates de l'air et à
l'instant on apprend que l'appareil a
atterri en effet à moscou et qu'il
pourrait peut-être repartir vers
l'europe
l'accord de paix en irlande du nord sous
pression plutôt sous conditions tant que
l'ira n'aura pas déposé les armes
demain le gouvernement britannique
envisage à contrecoeur de geler dans
l'avenir l'assemblée le gouvernement
autonome de l'irlande du nord
s'il n'obtient pas gestes concrets de
l'ira pour éviter la crise venant
dickens une nouvelle fois l'irlande du
nord suspend son souffle son parlement
son gouvernement qui siège dans ce
palais de stormont risque bien d'être
suspendu d'ici la fin de la semaine
il ya deux mois pourtant les choses
s'annonçaient plutôt bien car pour la
première fois depuis 25 ans catholiques
et protestants s'apprêtait à gouverner
ensemble
seule ombre au tableau le leader
unioniste david trimble avait prévenu
qu'il démissionnerait de son poste de
premier ministre s'il ira ne s'engageait
pas concrètement d'ici février sur la
voie du désarmement
en février nous y sommes et rien ne
s'est passé ou presque il ira refuse de
céder à cet ultimatum et réaffirme
qu'elle n'a pris elle même aucun
engagement en matière de désarmement
l'accord de paix du vendredi saint était
conclue avec le shin fine sa branche
politique est la seule date butoir qu'il
prévoit c'est juin 2000 dès lors les
pressions politiques s'accentuent sur
gerry adams pour obtenir ce geste qui
permettrait de sauver les institutions
d'irlande du nord
mais pour l'instant en vain vraiment que
quelqu'un va se présenter en disant
qu'il dira et livrer les détails sur la
quantité la composition de son arsenal
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu une armée
invaincu faire ce genre de déclaration
n'importe où dans le monde
pourtant faute d'un signe tangible en
matière de désarmement d'ici la fin de
la semaine tony blair a bien l'intention
de suspendre le gouvernement d'irlande
du nord mais le ch in fine la prévenue
la dernière fois que les autorités
britanniques ont ainsi suspendu les
institutions d'irlande du nord
c'était en 75 il avait fallu vingt-cinq
années de troubles et des milliers de
morts avant de les rétablir vous été
signé dans quelques heures hillary
clinton sera officiellement candidate au
poste de sénateur de l'état de new york
une cérémonie ou plutôt une opération
très médiatique devrait donner le coup
d'envoi de la campagne avec son premier
discours devant une forêt de caméras
ces dernières semaines hillary clinton
s'était déjà lancée dans la bataille et
portrait d'une battante dominique derda
c'était l'été dernier dans le nord de
l'état de new york
hillary clinton n'est pas encore
officiellement candidate au poste de
sénateur que déjà elle part en campagne
à l'écho du thelle des préoccupations
des new york pour la première fois de
l'histoire de ce pays les cous d'un
président des états unis s'apprête à
briguer un mandat électoral
et pas n'importe lequel j'imagine que
vous demandez tout ce pour quoi le sénat
pourquoi new york
et pourquoi moi à cette question
pourtant elle n'a jamais vraiment
répondu sur son passage dès le premier
jour les partisans de roddy giuliani le
maire républicain de la ville de new
york dénonce le parachutage de cette
native des environs de chicago
mais au sortir de la sphère levinsky
hillary clinton est populaire en février
68% des new yorkais disent apprécier
contre 61 % seulement
l'opinion favorable à rudi giuliani
l'ancien procureur a du souci à se faire
d'autant que la première dame en ménage
bientôt dans une banlieue cossue du nom
de chapa quoi et prend ainsi au sens
propre ses distances avec son président
de mari
retenu à washington jusqu'à la fin de
son mandat je dois bien vous avouer que
je m'intéresse beaucoup à cette
sénatoriales en particulier puisque
chaque voix compte
eh bien oui je vais masques sont les
listes électorales de new york à la
télévision c'est d'elle et non plus de
lui qu'elle vient parler de ses projets
en matière de santé d'emploi d'éducation
montrer aussi même si tout est écrit et
répété à l'avant ce qu'elle est capable
d'un éclat de rire
le stade le stade
c'est elle que l'on vient applaudir mais
c'est elle aussi qui désormais en
première ligne en est mauvais coup à
neuf mois les élections les sondages la
donnent loin derrière ou dit giuly a dit
même si rien n'est encore perdu à new
york peut être plus qu'ailleurs en neuf
mois
tout peut arriver en france cette
situation ubuesque que vivent les
chasseurs de la baie d'authie est la
limite entre deux départements celui du
pas-de-calais de la somme la frontière
qui les sépare leur impose une
réglementation différente ici le droit
de la chasse est autorisée et là il ne
l'est pas il a une verne et oeri de
l'agneau d'une rive à l'autre 30 mètres
séparent les chasseurs du pas de calais
de la somme limite géographique de ces
deux départements la baie d'authie aussi
le symbole du casse tête juridique de la
chasse française
une chasse autorisée dans le pas de
calais jusqu'au 29 février mais
totalement illégal juste en face ces
deux interprétations différentes de la
loi française ont mis le feu aux poudres
au médecin canalisée par ses décisions
alors qu'on avait déjà accepté de ne
plus chasser au mois de mars la fin
février c'est une date tout à fait
raisonnables conformément à la directive
européenne le tribunal d'amiens
raccourci la période de tir d'un mois
une décision inacceptable dans cette
région de picardie
l'un des bastions du parti des chasseurs
et gens de la campagne
qu'est ce qu'ils ont mais ils n'ont que
ça donc ça m'ennuie jamais prendre son
fusil n'embête personne il est dans la
nature ils votent son chien il faut pas
dire qu'on on est là qu on détruit c'est
pas vrai le chasseur c'est le premier
c'est nous qui avons fait des agrainoirs
c'est nous les zones celui ci a défendu
mine aujourd'hui pourquoi il ya des
zones humides c'est les chasseurs c'est
nos grands parents sinon européenne
pour les protecteurs de la nature
l'argument sonne faux d'autant que ces
chasseurs ont accepté de ne plus tirer
au mois de mars période de reproduction
en 1979 quand il avait s'agit de fermer
la chasse la chasse au mois de mars avec
la même détermination les chasseurs
défendez cette chasse est aujourd'hui la
plupart d'entre eux reconnaissent que
c'était une hérésie de chasser au même
marche forcée qui reconnaîtront jans
quelque chose année le plus tôt possible
sera le mieux que c'était une hérésie
le chassé au mois de février malgré les
risques de procès des remords
les chasseurs picard ne renoncerons pas
en occupant le terrain jusqu'à la fin du
mois
il renvoie le débat à l'année prochaine
les sports d'hiver avec ces dernières
années l'engouement pour les sports de
glisse une nouvelle clientèle qui
intéresse notamment les petites stations
prête à tout pour s'attacher ses
sportifs d'un autre genre en isère où
s'est clos à la new wave ski bruno
livertout la nuit des hommes et leurs
drôles de machines prépare des pistes
bizarres des pistes relevés sur les
bords ou bien pleine de bosses elles ont
tout ce qui permettra de bondy rebondir
ou tournoyer le lendemain matin
ces skieurs en fonction de leurs
techniques seront ride freerider aux
freestylers il n'y a pas de mode
équivalent français
bref ils se reconnaîtront
deux points communs les rapproche un il
dit sur une seule planche 2 ils ne se
prennent pas au sérieux
c'est la grève contestation parce qu'il
pense à tous les niveaux donc il ya
surtout des pistes de débutants et qui
sont bien préparés nouveau pavage et
donc on peut signifier cette clientèle
jeune et très recherchée pour l'attirer
certaines stations amorce la pompe en
faisant venir des étudiants champion de
snowboard séjour payé leur rôle consiste
être le plus possible sur les dix jeunes
qui font du snowboard ici qui sont un
stock club des sports on essaye un peu
de d&d des aiguilles et d'autre part ici
un half-pipe et un snowpark is entretenu
régulièrement on essaye d'apporter un
peu de connaissance de s'impliquer
vraiment dans déroulement des activités
sur les salles sombres sur le terrain
nos rangs et ses copains sont très
présents ils sont là pour donner une
image jeune à la station et c'est bien
sur ce que recherchent les jeunes la
possibilité de venir chez nous et d
écouter et puis de faire en sorte qu'ils
soient bien chez nous parce que ces
délits leur opinion quel service du
monde
eh bien ils nous rendent le service que
s'ils viennent chez nous d'autres gens
viennent chez nous
l'effet boule de neige ça marche le
nombre de skieurs sur deux planches
stagne mais celui des pratiquants de
snowboard augmente
une tendance que les professionnels de
la montagne surveille de près le tournoi
de tennis des petits as ainsi nommé
puisqu'il met en compétition des
adolescents du monde entier déjà
confirmé à tarbes cette semaine ses
graines de futurs champions se sont
affrontés sur les courts ou déjà dans le
passé martina hingis ou michael chang se
sont illustrés je viens et riche en et
abdel juillet ont suivi jusqu'en finale
un jeune espoir il s'appelle julien
peut-être un futur champion julien joly
à tout juste 14 ans lui et ses copains
de chambrée participent au tournoi de
tennis de tarbes le tournoi des petits
as
l'équivalent pour les jeunes de leur âge
d'un wimbledon ou d'un roland garros
pour les professionnels mais s'il s'agit
là du tournoi le plus renommés au monde
julien sait bien que pour atteindre ses
rêves la route est encore longue
il ya plein de joueurs tonguiens d'état
mais qui maintenant bas sont pas sont
pas dans les dix premiers joueurs se
souviennent ils ont même arrêté pénis
donc faut continuer comme je vais vont
pas s'arrêter là si jamais je gagne son
offre ou je continue après patrick
labazuy entraîne les meilleurs jeunes
français et julien joly a fortiori leçon
de tennis leçon de sagesse
le tournoi des petits as quoi que l'on y
fasse c'est l'occasion idéale de grandir
elle a travaillé avec julien sur le fait
que le plaisir est importante que bel
événement il est il est là et qu'il
fallait passe encore mais sur une
une obligation mais au contraire un
passage qui sera une excellente
expérience pour la suite de sa carrière
les anciens vainqueurs du tournoi
s'appelle michael chang kai shek
kournikova ou martina hingis
c'est dire l'importance d'un événement
qui accueille cette année 400 jeunes
talents de 50 nationalités différentes
laurent rizzo est un chasseur de têtes
la plupart du temps ils courent de cour
en cour
assistez à 500 matches par an ça laisse
peu de temps pour flâner
aujourd'hui il est arrivé au début de
celui de julien mais ne le verra pas
dans sa totalité
il scrute griffonne parce que c'est un
passionné qu'il en a fait son métier sa
quête c'est de débusquer les futurs
virtuoses de la raquette aussi d'avoir
le coup d'oeil et puis la sensibilité
maintenant la difficulté c'est
d'extrapoler est de savoir qui de tel ou
tel joueur ou joueuse va devenir fort
c'est à dire contre et un jours dans les
cent premiers mondiaux
tête de série numéro 3 julien joly a
battu son adversaire autrichien
julien n'est pas sûr ne côtoyez un jour
sans principes autres agassi mais il a
bon espoir
l'afad d'une difficile expédition
sanitaire dans l'antarctique
laurence de la ferrière a parcouru
3000km l'emmenant du pô sud la terre
adélie en 73 jours l'alpiniste française
affronter des vents atteignant 160 km
heure et des fatigués mais soulagés
cinéma avec cette légende fantastique
mise en scène par tim burton a monde de
conte de fées merveilleux
cauchemardesque que traverse avec talent
johnny depp déjà un succès aux états
unis pour le réalisateur de batman et
mars attacks
parce qu'elle défend
imaginez-vous enfants dans votre lit vos
parents vous lisent un conte plein de
sorcières et de forêt hantée c'est ainsi
que les petits américains ont grandi
avec la légende du cavalier sans tête
c'est ainsi que tim burton la restitue
aujourd'hui en rendant hommage aux films
d'horreur des années 50
je lisais pas interprète un jeune
inspecteur de police qui débarque dans
un village terrorisé etc étaient sur les
meurtres de sibiu que vous expliquez vos
supérieurs
ils ont dit que tous les trois ont été
tués en plein air et que leurs têtes
avaient été séparés de leur corps
emportés par le cavalier seul en tête
puisque l'enfer avec lui washington je
pense que si washington irving l'auteur
du compte avait imaginées ont 18 120 que
son histoire serait un jour porté sur le
grand écran ils en avaient rêvé
alors il aurait sûrement choisi tim
burton pour réaliser le film
on dirait que cette histoire a été
écrite pour lui vous avez déplacé le
corps su très jeune il ne faut jamais
déplacé le corps pourquoi dans parce que
tim burton s'est régalé en recréant un
univers fantastique où s'affrontent le
bien et le mal le surnaturel et
rationnelle et s'il ya de la violence
dans sleepy hollow
c'est celle des contes de fées
l'agresseur a rejoint et avec du mas bas
il a fait volte-face
est revenu sur ses pas s'emparer de la
tête du malheureux les comptes de ce
genre sont le moyen le plus sûr
d'exorciser nos zones d'or les films
fantastiques qui ne prétendent pas être
réaliste servez le même choix
moi j'ai un problème avec une autre
forme de violence
par exemple quand deux types branchés se
tirent dessus en échangeant des blagues
aux plaintes d'autres gens pour moi
celle là est beaucoup plus dangereuse le
sim burton signe là un petit bijou du
film d'or ont ri ont tremblé lorsque les
lumières se rallument on se dit que
c'est bon de retrouver ses peurs
d'enfant c'est la fin de ce journal je
vous rappelle principal titre
catastrophe ferroviaire en allemagne
la vitesse excessive pourrait être à
l'origine du déraillement de l'express
venant d'amsterdam avec 300 passagers à
bord bilan provisoire
neuf morts 20 blessés graves dans un
instant la météo de nathalie rihouet
puis à 20h55 votre film jean de florette
seront leurs 15 le dernier journal
florence duprat demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités françoise laborde reçoit
florence parly secrétaire d'état au
budget à 13h le journal carole gaessler
rachid arhab à 20h vous retrouverez
claude sérillon et puis en deuxième
partie de programme de man les hôpitaux
sont ils malades
ce sera donc le thème de l'émission mots
croisés dans les travaux alain duhamel
invité des médecins des infirmières des
directeurs d'hôpitaux mais aussi le
professeur bernard debré claude evin qui
est ancien ministre de la santé
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
nous